the horrors of the war on Gaza on full
display in the security Council with
urgent calls to help civilians on both
sides front and center the UN Secretary
General says it's not enough to blame
Hamas it is important to also recognize
the attacks by amas did not happen in a
vacuum the Palestinian people have been
subjected to 56 years of suffocating
occupation the comment unacceptable to
Israel who demanded his resignation but
Russia China the UAE among many council
members calling for an immediate
ceasefire a call that was noticeably
absent from the draft resolution the US
had hoped to put to a
vote the key Point here is the need for
a swift ceasefire the fact that it was
not included in the council draft was a
step in the wrong direction and could be
interpreted as Council support for
Israel's plan to conduct a ground
offensive in Gaza Russia countered the
US with its own ceasefire resolution
while the UAE and other Arab states said
the only hope is a two-state
solution we're facing a spiral of
violence a war based on despair over
Decades of occupation Injustice and
oppression innocent people are being
killed the US says it's working
tirelessly to get Aid to Gaza while
blaming Iran and its proxies for fueling
the conflict if Iran or its proxies
attack us personnel and
anywhere make no mistake we will defend
our people we will defend our security
swiftly and decisively Iran's Ambassador
accuses the United States of
exacerbating the conflict by overtly
aligning itself with Israel passionate
speeches and intense diplomacy have so
far failed to yield a unified position
in the security Council prompting the
Arab League and the organization of
Islamic cooperation to offer their own
resolution for a ceasefire in the
general assembly later this week there
no country has the power to veto it
Kristen salumi Al jazer the United
Nations